so in the three or so years it shows
Brown the air we've taken a bunch of
different positions on a bunch of
different topics but one thing we've
always been consistent about from the
first day till today is making fun of
Bill DeBlasio of the mayor of New York
on every topic if you watch a show you
know then the other day it came to our
attention that de Blasio has raised an
issue that too few in either party are
talking about it's the question of
automation he's got a piece in Wired
magazine on - as you as you know is also
running for president something else
we've made fun of but his position or
automation really struck us is pretty
interesting so yesterday we arranged a
phone call and we talked with a very
friendly conversation invited mayor de
Blasio to come on the show to talk about
that and other things and he was
gracious enough to respond and so we're
happy to have Mayor Bill de Blasio join
us tonight live mr. mayor thanks a lot
for coming on Thank You Tucker and I
appreciate that you care deeply about
this issue Automation because it's
bearing down on all of us it is it is
and I and and my praise of you on this
question is totally sincere very few
people are taking this seriously Andrew
yang is one of them you're another I
can't think of many others who are and
so so god bless you so you're basically
saying that companies ought to have to
and I'm not sure how much of this I
agree with but I think I'm phrasing this
correctly you say companies ought to
have to bear some of the cost of helping
workers transition to something else
when they lay them off in favor of
robots that's right Tucker right now
let's let's just get the magnitude clear
for all your viewers middle-class
Americans working-class Americans whose
jobs are not going to be there if we
don't do something different there's
right now the recent estimate estimate I
saw 36 million jobs that could be made
obsolete we're talking as early as 2030
12 years ahead 11 12 years from now so
here's the reality right now in fact the
federal tax code rewards companies that
invest in the kind of technology that
actually sheds jobs destroys jobs our
tax dollars are helping companies
incentivizing companies to get rid of
more and more American workers so my
plan is simple it says and that we're
talking about hundreds of billions of
dollars that we could use
to actually address our bigger issues in
this country I'm completely with you on
that one right there I'm sure there's a
lot of details we disagree on but I
agree with you on that
and by the way South Korea is doing that
right now they recognize that they don't
stop incentivizing companies a lot of
times these companies are making the
decision simply because it's better for
their tax reality rather than what's
better for working people or even
productivity the second point of my plan
is
let's institute something that Bill
Gates actually was the first one I think
to call for which is a quote unquote
robot tax it says simply you know a
worker pays income tax you take away
millions and millions of workers that's
a lot less revenue to take care of all
the things we need in our society and it
means of course millions and millions of
people don't have a livelihood I believe
in work I think you do too I believe we
need a future that's based on work so if
a company is going to put the housings
of people out of work they should bear
responsibility for making sure those
folks get a new job either in the same
company or elsewhere that tax is both an
incentive to keep people on the job in a
good way in a productive way right also
provides money to help foster from the
federal level the kinds of things we
need a lot more of we need a lot more
investment in renewable energy and
recycling and environmental restitution
there's all sorts of ask you this
question though okay so I'm not sure I
think of the second but I don't think
it's totally crazy you know happy to
read and think about it more so we're
together up until this point but if you
really believe that automation is a
threat to low-skilled jobs
why are you for mass immigration what
are all these people gonna do we're
importing with your help
look Tucker I'm gonna finish the point
about what we're trying to achieve here
and I certainly want to answer that
question it's an important one
let's just be clear about the central
point here right now there is no
American strategy no federal government
strategy to address automation and it
could be the single most disruptive
force in our society that we've ever
experienced if you talk about tens of
millions of working-class and
middle-class Americans who no longer
have work or the prospect to work that's
unacceptable so the federal government
has to step up there is no strategy now
there's no candidate in my opinion who's
offering a coherent strategy I respect
and agree
in immigration is a club second as a
force that transform in the country and
the tour at cross-purposes so
immigrants come here overwhelmingly to
work in low-skilled jobs a lot of those
jobs no matter how hard we try are going
away this is crazy why are we doing this
well let's face it there's a huge number
of jobs right now and let's take a Greek
ultra as an obvious example where we're
in the worst of all worlds we don't have
enough workers to do the work among the
people already in this country and we
don't have a coherent immigration system
including something as obvious as a
guest worker program illegal gasping
okay sector ok AG is and that's a
separate debate I disagree but that's
not I mean the much bigger picture is
jobs in the service sector are going
away that immigrants fill import
immigrants at over a million a year
while I appreciate your point the
magnitude here speaks otherwise again
let's take that number 36 million and
there are estimates that go a lot
farther than that Tucker we're not
talking about we're not talking about
the impact immigration compared now
we're talking about something absolutely
seismic and imagine I think you and I
share this concern I bet a huge
percentage of your viewers do too how do
we have a threat to our security to our
stability as a country to our social
fabric and there's no strategy
whatsoever in fact the recent tax
legislation made it worse encourage
companies to lay off more workers and to
put the funny engineer machines so what
you're saying and I agree with you is
that we have this massive problem that
everyone's ignoring and I and I want on
that point to transition to the city
that you run New York where I was
yesterday the city is dirty and it's
getting dirtier one of my producers told
me just yesterday that he was in a
crowded subway car and a man dropped his
trousers and defecated in the middle of
the car and no one did anything about it
and that's a metaphor for what's
happening I go there regularly and I
have my whole life and every time I go
under your mayorship it is dirtier
there's filth on the sidewalks do you
notice any event Tucker look here's
what's going on in New York City today
we have challenges no doubt and I don't
accept a situation like that I'm someone
who believes a quality of life has to be
addressed aggressively I believe
quality of life policing I always have
that kind of situation is unacceptable
but the big picture is we are the safest
big city in America it is proven
statistically time and time again we
have five hundred thousand new jobs
since I became mayor the largest number
of jobs in our history right now the
strongest economy we've ever had we got
problems unquestionably but there's also
a lot of areas where the city is doing
very very well and the bottom line here
is that we're address it okay but do you
you endorsed decriminalizing public
urination no absolutely that's
absolutely no listen any offense like
that gets a summons there's a penalty
there's definitely a sanction we don't
believe in that you weaken the sanction
against public urination this smells
like urine you notice that's true I go
all over New York City all the time I'm
sorry I've been here for decades and
decades this city is more orderly and
cleaner and safer than has been for many
many years we got more to do and we're
gonna keep making it better
but anyone 14,000 more homeless people
on the street than the day you took off
that's not that's really their fault
that's just not true well that it's not
so in the bottom line here it's actually
a little more than 14 it's almost 15
with 64,000 60 the day your predecessor
left and now it's 78 bucks a week we
obviously we can reason together there
is a federal count every year the number
of homeless on the street is give or
take four thousand there's a lot of
people the shelter system that's true
we're driving down that number we're
driving down a number on the street I am
NOT happy even about four thousand
people on the street but it's just
nowhere near what you just said but the
difference at what you can see in New
York and you see it on safety and you
see it on jobs and you see it on a
higher graduation rate in our schools is
we continue to make progress in the city
we're going to make a lot more but to
the original decree question let me ask
you a concrete question if I if I live
in New York and there's a homeless man
outside my building who defecates on the
sidewalk is defecating on the sidewalk
grounds to be arrested in the city it
certainly can't look it it certainly can
be anybody want to see something like
that
now hold on No then you arrested if I
have you along on the side what can you
be arrested for defecating and prevented
from living anyone who is a threat to
themselves or other anyone who violates
a law anyone who's aggressive towards
other people there's a whole host of
standards by which someone could be
arrested and we do that and we'll
continue to do that but again the bottom
line here is we're talking about real
issues here but what we should be
talking about all the time we should be
talking about all the working people the
future working people in this country
and where you and I started I'm coming
back if we don't and we're two of the
only people talking about it right now
if we don't deal with the fact that tens
of millions of American workers may not
have a job and we may have a future
without work and our social fabric could
be destroyed and that's a threat to
American security we don't deal with
this in this election we're gonna ruin
the day we're gonna actually do
something about it and as a
non-political essentially non partisan
person I'm I am absolutely happy to
compliment you with total sincerity on
that I'm just saying the reality the
actual reality of life in the city that
you manage matters is the biggest city
in our country I've lived there on and
off my whole life that city is not
getting better under your mayor shucker
I don't know example unless you don't
believe in the NYPD statistics unless
you don't believe the NYPD which
consistent we had a we yesterday had a
press conference we laid out the crime
statistics for this year and crime
continues to go down year after year
it's an extraordinary effort by the NYPD
using policies and strategies that I've
instituted in my administration as part
of what's working how do you have five
hundred thousand new jobs in six years
how do you have a record number of
tourists if it's this you were aboard
you were arguing across what I'm saying
you're ignoring what else and so okay so
so the city is doing so well then you
have a net inflow of people into New
York City oh no just the opposite you
lost 40,000 people in the last year we
have an eight points
million residents eight point six
million residents the highest we've ever
had are his forty thousand we have the
highest population is that in our
history no we have the highest
population in our history that's what
matters people are investing in this
city because it's working Tucker I'm the
first to say cuz I do live here and I
feel everything have been here for
decades and decades we've got some
things to work on for sure
we've got some areas where we're not
where we need to be but when you go back
to the central question Tucker do people
create say yeah most New Yorkers are
most New Yorkers are liberal so they
agree with you on the macro issues I
think if you were to say what does Bill
DeBlasio to believe what does your
average New Yorker believe there's a lot
of overlap maybe a total overlap but if
you were to ask your average New Yorker
has Bill de Blasio done such a good job
in New York City that he deserves to run
the United States of America what
percentage do you think would say yes
I don't conjecture I know that they
actually got to vote twice 73 percent my
first election the question is when
especially in a race for president what
have you actually done that makes you
able to be president eyes days I've run
the biggest most complex city in this
country again we've the safest we've
ever been the strongest economy we've
ever been we're the most diverse place
and our social fabrics a lot stronger
than it was six years ago there's a lot
I can show you that actually has to do
with how you run something and move
something forward and where we started
I'm talking about issues related to
working people that bluntly neither
Democrats or Republicans talk enough
about and my whole reason for coming
from here was to address the issues of
working people and that's what we've
been able to do here in this city so the
biggest private-sector employers who are
the biggest private-sector employers in
New York City Chase Manhattan is one
great example yes
chase chase is number one JP Morgan
Chase JP Morgan Chase the leaders does
the leader show so they would obviously
I mean they're the biggest private
sector employer in the city that you run
the biggest city in America so obviously
the head of that company Jamie Dimon
must be a huge supporter of yours and a
big donor to your presidential campaign
because you've made the city so it
doesn't you know this logic pattern just
doesn't hold the question is this you
got me for president you got
yato well why is that I wonder because
we have different views and I respect
him but we have different views we and
by the way a CEO of a major financial
institution is the last kind of person I
think would support me because I believe
we have to be tougher on Wall Street I
believe we have to stand up for working
people I believe we need to tax the
wealthy a lot more than we are it's this
regressive
why would you think the CEO of working
people would support someone like me
that is concerned about working people
class people then it's your question
because you're the mayor of the city and
they have tens of thousands of employees
living their City and some of what's not
ideological I don't think that Jamie
Dimon the head of the company is a
conservative he's not it's not about the
ideology it's not about the banks it's
about whether you're making the city
back look I know I know him and I
respect him and I think he often speaks
about important issues but we have a
very different world view and it doesn't
surprise me that he would not support
someone who wants to tax the wealthy a
lot more and wants to challenge Wall
Street and believes that we gotta do a
lot more employ who supports you
question just one question don't play
these games I don't play these games
here's the game it's a party the
Democratic Party for too long has been
way too cozy with donors with Wall
Street with folks who actually read a
lot of our problems when the whole
reason we're having a good conversation
in summation is I don't care about what
those donors think I don't care about
what folks in Silicon Valley who are
trying to justify that technology
somehow going to save us all you know
they're they're resting their laurels on
the universal basic income and this is
another fallacy Tucker ubi maybe it's
part of a solution in some way shape or
form but what I fear about that kind
idea is it so it's a crutch it's a way
for a bunch of people gonna make a huge
amount of money just to make their own
consciousness feel better but what it's
going to lead to is a future without
work and the last thing is I'm a
progressive I'm a Democrat
I believe in work and I believe work
gives people a lot of value a lot of
meaning and we need to protect work in
this country and there's a whole lot of
wealthy people or happy to run all the
way
bank and leave working people behind and
then they'll say oh you say ho we'll
send you a check and that's ridiculous
you're right and and by the way if
you've ever known inherited money people
they're the unhappiest people in America
so obviously you don't want to encourage
indolence so quick final question yeah
how can you take an SUV to the gym and
back everyday and say that you're really
worried about so it's a it's a it's a
chrysler pacifica for years it's a
Pacifica it's a hybrid electric it's not
an SUV first of all but it's look I come
with an illusion in it I come from a
neighborhood I go back to my
neighborhood all the time it's the way
to me that I stay connected to people
that I am able to have a routine that
allows me to be 24/7 the best mayor I
can be but should the climate have to
pay the cost for them on its a few miles
come on and Tucker here's the great part
about all this about climate change oh
come on no no no no the point is
wherever I go if I take a subway the
cars follow me for security reasons any
way you slice it I'm doing what's going
to help me be the best that I can be for
the people in this city and that's why
I'm proud to say this is a city just
safest big city America a city that's
moving forward in so many ways but if we
don't get these bigger issues right and
I got to tell you yeah you could be
mayor and you can feel like wow I'm
mayor I'm able to do things but if
Washington doesn't address the kinds of
things that cities and states can't do
if Washington doesn't address this
automation issue we're all screwed we're
all okay this better be at 20:20 issues
and it's not right now it's not a 2020
vision even and we need to make it 20
whether you're gonna stay in the race
we're gonna take a quick break will you
stay there I want to ask you are you
gonna keep running for president